in the days after the election there has
been a lot of talk about the Democrat
party's dominance among young voters and
indeed they did in fact dominate
Republican house candidates won the 45
to 64 age bracket by 10 points they won
the 65 and over Group by even more than
that no surprise given that the
Democrats spent the entire you know
covid uh uh pandemic trying to murder
the elderly but that edge disappears in
the 30 to 44 demographic where Democrats
had a slight Edge it's almost 50 50
though and then there is Gen Z which
Democrats won by nearly 30 points
if the exit poll data is any indication
nearly twice as many in the 18 to 29
group voted Democrat as voted Republican
so that's gen Z and like the first part
of you know the the later parts of uh of
the millennial generation as well it's
no surprise to learn then that gen Z is
extremely mentally ill at least
according to the latest study uh which
uh we get this from the Christian post
it has the report nearly 70 percent of
Generation Z people born between 1997
and 2012 say their mental health was
adversely impacted by the kova 19
pandemic with 42 percent of adult
members of the cohort reporting that
they have been diagnosed with a mental
health condition and many of them say
they're worried about the future a new
study from the data management firm
Harmony Healthcare I.T shows the study
which is based on a survey of 1055 gen Z
members from the ages of 18 to 24 in
September included 47 men 45 percent
women six percent who identify as
non-binary and two percent trans
identified individuals according to the
report some 57 percent of gen Z adults
struggle with their mental health uh and
reported taking medication to alleviate
their condition and uh paid in an
average of 44 dollars monthly the most
frequently cited conditions where
anxiety and depression which were
reported by 90 percent and 78 percent of
respondents respectively other
conditions reported include ADHD 27 PTSD
20 OCD 17 Eating Disorders 14 and
insomnia 12 less than 10 percent
reported uh more diagnoses of bipolar
disorder uh addiction and substance
abuse and borderline personality
disorder while only one in five reported
going to therapy for their mental health
and um spending an average of 149
dollars monthly to do so 87 percent of
them found it helpful
okay so nearly half of an entire
Generation Now qualify as mentally ill
according to their diagnosis
when you break it down the numbers seem
to become even more troubling
20 of that group allegedly have been
diagnosed with PTSD
nearly 20 percent with OCD 14 with an
eating disorder I mean these are
staggering figures
and however we make sense of it all it's
clear that something is very wrong here
to put it mildly so how do we make sense
of it well to that end I'll make three
points there are a lot more than three
points worth making here but these are
the three things that I'd like to focus
on
right now
first
mental illness is a real thing there are
legitimate mental illnesses that people
suffer from
but the only way you end up with half of
a generation diagnosed mentally ill is
if the definition of mental illness has
been steadily expanded so as to include
everyone or as close to everyone as they
can get as I've warned for years these
so-called mental health industry has a
vested interest an obvious financial
interest to the tune of many billions of
dollars in finding labeling and
medicating as many mental illnesses as
they possibly can
we're at a point now where
you know every emotion you might
experience every fear every anxiety
every uncomfortable feeling or thought
has been turned into an illness or the
symptom of an illness
The Human Condition itself has been
medicalized
and gen Z has grown up in a culture
where every inner experience outside of
the norm however the hell the norm is
defined
is considered a symptom of a mental
disease they have been conditioned to
seek the Solace of a mental of a medical
diagnosis and so it is uh no surprise
that they have sought and found so many
of them
now
does that mean
just so I'm not misunderstood here
does that mean that the mental illness
epidemic in young people is fake
no it means that it's manufactured which
is certainly not the same thing as fake
I mean it's there's something real
happening here but it is manufactured
eventually the entire generation I mean
literally almost all of them if these
Trends continue
will be diagnosed mentally ill
and although many of these Newfound
mental patients never should have been
diagnosed to begin with they will
increasingly become as mentally sick as
the medical industry says they are it's
a self-fulfilling prophecy
why is that because they're not given
the tools to cope with normal emotional
and psychological experiences they are
made to rely on medication
they are made to feel helpless
like they simply cannot control their
own minds or their own emotions or how
they respond to those emotions
and the sicker they're made to feel the
sicker they'll become and act
I mean think of all the people in gen Z
saying they have PTSD
you know PTSD is something we normally
think of of uh you know people veteran
combat veterans coming home from war and
think about all the things that they've
experienced and seen and they're
suffering from PTSD now that makes sense
you've been in a in a truly traumatic
environment
but to have 20 percent of this group
saying they have PTSD
these are these aren't for the most part
combat veterans we're talking about
and yes they've been through some
difficult things the way that we handled
covid was was absolutely inexcusable of
course but
post-traumatic stress disorder
these are many of them people living
very comfortable lives
so what does the PTSD diagnosis comes
from comes from
it comes from kids and now young adults
who have not been given the tools to
cope with any difficult emotions at all
they just don't know how to deal with
anything
and so any challenge at all becomes
traumatic and they're now suffering from
PTSD
you know the religion of leftism is
anti-religion which means that there
isn't anyone to turn to when things
don't go their way there's no
Transcendent being pointing you toward
truth and Beauty there are no Customs or
Traditions to keep you on a righteous
path and there's certainly no app like
hallow to help leftists reclaim their
piece but we do have that Halo is an
audio guided prayer meditation app it's
the number one Christian pair app in the
U.S how low is like calm or headspace
but without all the woke nonsense
because it's rooted in Christian faith
with thousands of meditations and
prayers I use Halo to find peace after a
long day of being yelled at by blue
haired zazam weirdos they have over five
thousand audio guided prayers
meditations and Christian music you can
pray alongside Jim Caviezel Jonathan
roomie Bishop Baron father Mike Schmitz
and Mark Wahlberg hello helps me make
prayer a priority they can do the same
for you you can get exclusive
three-month trial at hallow.com Matt
Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh reclaim your piece in this
crazy world download hello today
again it's manufactured there is an
enormous generation white epidemic of
Munchausen by proxy happening right now
that's basically what's happened
speaking of which the second point is
that gender ideology is without question
one of the primary driving forces here
this is something that conservatives
often get wrong I think because they
confuse the chicken with the egg it's
not that so many in gen Z identify as
non-binary or trans or whatever because
they're mentally ill it's rather that so
many are mentally ill because they have
been given these identities through peer
pressure and the powers of social
Contagion
the Adolescent girl who first begins to
fall into the trans trap she's not sick
there's no mental illness driving that
at least there doesn't have to be but
once she falls into the Trap completely
that is when the mental sickness begins
to form and take hold so for a good
example of this phenomenon here's the
latest Tick Tock Innovation one of the
latest identities fresh uh you know it's
a one of the one of the freshest ones uh
right out of the oven it's called try
gender watch this
so a couple of people might have been
surprised by my transgender pin that I
put on this morning
I figured it's about time that I came
out and talked about my gender identity
I am trigender which means like a
triangle I have three genders male
female and non-binary
and the difference between trigender and
gender fluid is that I feel all three of
these genders at the same time
all the time it doesn't ever shift or
change or where I feel one gender more
strongly than the other like gender
fluid tends to be
also I should recognize and accept that
a lot of people don't see non-binary as
a third gender they see it as something
completely separate from the binary of
male and female but for me
it's like a third gender
or I guess you could call it a Third
identity
so how I feel gender wise is like a man
like a woman and as neither at the same
time
I hope this clears things up but let me
know if you have any more questions I'm
happy to answer
actually quite a lot she says she's male
female both and neither at the same time
now that obviously makes no sense at all
it's the definition of a logical foul so
you cannot be something and the opposite
of that thing at the same time it's like
identifying as a married Bachelor it is
a self-contradiction
so is the girl in the video Simply crazy
is she suffering from mental delusions
it's possible and appearances would
suggest that such is the case
but it need not be the case
what's more likely is that she's simply
trying to fit in with the fad and find
her own trendy Twist on it but the more
that she tries to live in this
nonsensical identity the more confused
she will actually become the more
detached from reality and the more
plagued by anxiety at the same time I
mean keep in mind as I am always saying
that that um you know the really
Sinister thing about gender ideology and
is that when someone becomes fully
enthralled to it they will have lost
grip not just on reality in general but
on the reality of themselves
and there's a lot that comes from this
and one of those things is anxiety
because anxiety is the unease that comes
from uncertainty it comes from the
unknown it's why you know you don't like
uh walking down into a dark basement at
night because you don't know what's down
there and uh your mind sort of fills in
the gaps with all the terrifying
possibilities that's why Joe Biden's
handlers become very nervous whenever he
steps in front of a microphone because
they have no idea what he's going to say
or whatever you know childhood story
he's going to make up this is all
anxiety so gender ideology is like an
anxiety machine because it makes a
person's fundamental physical identity
uncertain to themselves creating a sort
of unrelenting anxiety
it's no surprise then that gen Z are
reporting record levels of anxiety
at precisely the time when these kinds
of ideas are gaining prominence
ideas which in effect turn out the
intellectual lights
turning our minds into that dark scary
basement
which brings me to my third point
um I said at the beginning that it's no
surprise that gen Z voted Democrat
because so many are diagnosed mentally
ill and I wasn't being facetious there
at least I wasn't being entirely
facetious facetious there is a
relationship it does actually make a lot
of sense
because we know with Gen z uh not only
does this make them susceptible to to
Identity politics and all of that that
the Democrats can exploit
but also because they have all of this
anxiety in their heads uh in their minds
and they don't know what to do with it
and they don't know how to cope with it
again having anxiety is a normal thing
it's part of the human condition
nobody likes it but it's part of the
human it's one of the things that makes
us human is that we can experience
anxiety
by the Democrat Party thrives on
exploiting anxiety
that's how they motivate people to vote
if you listen to things that gen Z you
know their exit poll data what were they
concerned about why did they go to the
poll to vote it's things like climate
change
you know they're actually worried about
that
they think the world's coming to an end
they think that America systemically
races that there are white supremacists
murderers walking around out there you
know
this is this is their view of the world
they're full of anxiety the Democrat
Party is able to exploit it and convert
that into votes
which is why as I've been saying all
along
we have a long road ahead in this fight
for the culture
and the fight is in in every sense of
the term generational
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]